sie ist riesig die welle der solidarität
mit den karikaturisten von charlie hebdo
die mit scharfer feder kämpften und mit
kalaschnikows getötet worden sind
der terrorüberfall auf die pariser
satire redaktion bei dem zwölf menschen
ruchlos ermordet worden sind bewegt
millionen von menschen die sich fragen
bringt das attentat die meinungsfreiheit
weltweit in gefahr
gleichzeitig fragen auch leute die die
morde von paris ohne wenn und aber
verurteilen darf satire alles oder hat
die meinungsfreiheit grenzen
aus aktuellem anlass haben wir unser
programm umgestellt und ich spreche
heute über diese fragen mit marco
ratschiller er ist chefredaktor des
schweizer satiremagazins nebelspalter
mit franz schöne waller ist professor
für politische philosophie an der
universität zürich und mit res strehle
ist chefredaktor des tages anzeigers
umso schöner war als ich sie angerufen
habe und spontan gefragt habe ob sie
zeit und interesse hätten in dieser
sendung zu kommen haben sie gesagt sie
hätten sich eigentlich gerade
zurückziehen wollen um an einem buch zu
schreiben aber sie könnten sich sowieso
nicht konzentrieren weil sie diese
ereignisse sehr beschäftigen was konkret
hat sie am meisten beschäftigt diese
unverhältnismäßigkeit nicht wahr dass
menschen die eigentlich nichts anderes
tun aus schreiben und zeichnen also
künstlerisch journalistisch tätig sind
das die getötet werden michael
mörderisch einfach nur deswegen weil sie
irgendetwas gezeichnet haben was
anstößig ist und was nicht gefallen hat
das hat mich durcheinander gebracht weil
ich natürlich auch in einem beruf
arbeiten wo man darauf angewiesen ist
30 häusern zu können auch sich
vielleicht verletzlich fühlt nicht
selber für mich aber für alle diejenigen
die sich sehr viel mehr exponieren vor
allem journalisten nicht waren und
künstler
herr strehle was ist in ihrer
journalisten seele vorgegangen als sie
vom attentat gehört haben haben sie so
etwas wie angst den kunden sich
möglicherweise auch nicht mehr so frei
über den islam äußern zu können oder
haben sie mehr so etwas wie wut
empfunden im stile von jetzt erst recht
weil angst haben wir nicht punkten aber
sicher ist eine empörung in der ganzen
branche der ganzen öffentlichkeit eine
betroffenheit eine trauer spürbar
es wurden die drei säulen denke ich
miteinander jetzt angegriffen mit diesem
attentat
der öffentliche diskurs der freie
diskurs die medien und was mir wichtig
erscheint die den humor als sie aber die
form der satire mit damit mit
gesellschaftlichen konflikten umzugehen
und alle diese zahl erscheint mir recht
essentiell für die für die demokratie zu
sein
mit diesem zusammenhang von humor und
demokratie werden wir bestimmt noch
sprechen dann haben sie auch so
herausgestrichen ihren leitartikel mit
dem sie dann reagiert haben auf dieses
attentat heraus schiller
sie sind chefredaktor eine satire
magazins und im moment auf allen kanälen
gefragt was ist für sie an diesem tag
passiert an diesem tag listenplatz ich
war selber natürlich wirklich auch
schockiert ich habe einen anderen
satirischen text gearbeitet in dem
moment als die news reinkam und ich war
vier minuten heimlich perplex wusste ich
gar nicht reden ich wusste dass ich
jetzt etwas ändern wird wahrscheinlich
für uns satiriker nicht dass sich das
ändern sollte aber es ist schwierig mit
dem umzugehen
und dann hat eigentlich auch schon das
erste telefon geklingelt um mich dazu zu
befragen wie das widersetzt weitergeht
für die satire
das könnte sich ändern das mit der
schere im kopf halt dass man sich obwohl
jetzt eigentlich jeder sich auch
vornimmt ich möchte mich nicht ändern
ich möchte die arbeit weiter machen
klingt halt doch auch im gespräch mit
kollegen durch eine gewisse angst ist
ein gewisses eine gewisse befürchtung
dass man sich jetzt nicht eine
selbstzensur übt und gar nicht mehr an
themen genau gleich ran gehen könnte wie
man das bisher getan hat jetzt hat man
ja an vielen orten gelesen das war eben
nicht nur ein angriff auf charlie hebdo
sondern dieses attentat hat den westen
getroffen
als philosoph schönewald zusammenhang
zwischen meinungsäusserungsfreiheit
demokratie der westen darum ist die
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit dermaßen
wichtig für uns also ich würde sagen den
westen das will ich nicht angebracht das
hat all jene getroffen die für
freiheitliche werte einstehen und die
gibt es natürlich überall auf der welt
es hat die freiheitliche gesellschaft
getroffen weil die
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit ist wirklich
der sauerstoff einer jeden
freiheitlichen gesellschaft und das
wurde angegriffen und das scheint mir so
beklemmend zu sein ich weiß sie sein als
der eines der höchsten not zentralen
werte man sieht es auch an der reaktion
ich war es finden sich plötzlich leute
die sonst in der gegnerschaft in
politischer gegnerschaft gegeneinander
stehen die finden sich sofort in einem
basis konsens über die meinungsfreiheit
denke vielleicht kann man sogar einen
schritt weiter gehen das hat nicht nur
nicht den westen spezifisch getroffen
sondern eigentlich jene gesellschaften
die transit zu öffnen aus werden die
große hoffnung war noch der rat mit
europäischen revolution die der ganze
konflikt die mir an diesen ländern ist
eigentlich diese warnung noch noch sehr
sehr viel stärker nicht ein wenn es
grund gibt angst zu haben dann dort
nicht also ich denke hier ist die ist
die ist die gefahr relativ klein im
vergleich aber dort sehen wir wie die
tägliche viele menschen auch viele
frauen in dieser ganzen
auseinandersetzung seit viel viel mehr
riskiert und das ist denke ich die die
die warnung nicht dir die damit
abgegeben wird natürlich trifft seien
auch die medien triebs auch den westen
aber es ist ein konflikt zwischen
zwischen lässt und im westen und dem
rest der welt nicht sehr viele
muslimische organisationen haben sich ja
sehr sehr klar distanziert von diesem
ort in tagesgeld ist ja auch kein
bekennerschreiben
insofern kann man sich ja vielleicht
auch fragen sind nicht vor allem auch
die muslime diejenigen die jetzt ein
großes problem haben nun die verloren
haben
ja also ich denke wir von den reaktionen
seite glaube ich nicht dass sie das die
frauen haben sondern es zeigt das zeigt
ja sehr viel betroffenheit ihn auch in
sektoren der gesellschaft fragen auch in
der muslimischen teilen und ich habe ich
habe eher den eindruck auch wie die
medien reagiert haben das ist nicht
deine also dieses kalkül der attentäter
geht nicht darauf nicht ich habe nicht
den eindruck dass jetzt die die medien
sich einschüchtern lassen
ich habe nicht den eindruck dass die
gesellschaft sich stärker sport bis
jetzt nicht aufgrund reaktions kann sich
natürlich noch ändern nicht wenn jetzt
mobilisiert wird wie das zu befürchten
von einzelnen bewegungen in deutschland
in frankreich von den nach rechts aussen
parteien dann könnte das dass gauck will
noch ausgehen dass auch wenn ich das ist
auch meine hoffnung dass sich das nicht
ändert auch wenn ich wenn ich
zurückdenke an den ersten
karikaturenstreit 2006 in dänemark
ausgelöst da hat sich der diskurs ein
bisschen anders entwickelt und man hat
doch offen darüber gesprochen haben die
karikaturisten dort nicht provoziert ist
das nicht auch eine zeitschrift gewesen
die zu fest rechtsaußen operiert und der
diskus der jetzt heute so verläuft dass
man sich ein einhellig hinter faktor
stellt der verlief damals ein bisschen
anders und ich habe einfach die hoffnung
dass das jetzt nicht dann mit der zeit
auch wieder in dieser bahn verläuft
was meinen sie konkret mit damals hat
man ein bisschen die opfer auch zu
tätern gemacht und gesagt man muss die
diskussion die jetzt die hier geführt
wird wie weitergehen und exponiert man
sich als satiriker nicht bewusst und
provoziert hat ein
einem gewaltakt der auf einen selbst
gerichtet ist und ich erinnere mich
einfach dazu 2006 die diskussion
wirklich nicht so klar verlaufen ist wie
es jetzt heute bis jetzt nach wenigen
tagen verlaufen ist muss natürlich auch
sagen das massaker ist in aller
deutlichkeit zu verurteilen niemand
würde das bestreiten
dennoch kann man natürlich davon
abgesehen darüber diskutieren wie weit
darf meinungsfreiheit gehen wie weit
darf satire gehen und gerade sie haben
sich ja damals eben sie erwähnen diesen
streit im karikaturenstreit damals
losgetreten worden ist sie erwähnen denn
sie haben sich damals entschieden im
nebelspalter diese karikaturen nicht zu
zeigen auch aus 2012 ja dann eben
charlie hebdo selber noch mit viel
schärferen karikaturen nachgezogen hat
selber aktiv wurde
haben sie auch gesagt drucken wir nicht
finden wir keine gute sache warum ich
muss vielleicht präzisieren 2006 haben
wird ziemlich umfassend uns damit
befasst wir haben damals mohammed
karikaturen wir haben gezeigt dass das
historisch nichts neues ist und dass man
das früher auch in den alten apple
stores gaben findet ohne dass das zu
kontroversen und aufruhr geführt hätte
2012 war es ein bisschen anders als
direktor das eigentlich nochmal aufs
tapet brachte haben wir uns gesagt sind
wir jetzt eigentlich verpflichtet immer
wenn ein anderes satiremagazin sowas
sagt müssen wir dann auch nachziehen
oder haben wir im sinne der
meinungsfreiheit auch einfach ungerecht
dass wir eine andere linie verfolgen wir
haben uns entschieden
mohammed karikaturen nicht mehr zu
zeigen weil dies ja eigentlich schon mal
getan haben und dem tabubruch der darin
besteht eigentlich nicht noch mal
gemacht werden muss aus unserer sicht
und der tabubruch das ist möchte ich
auch noch vielleicht auseinandersetzen
das tabu die darstellung des propheten
das bezieht sich ja auch nicht nur auf
satire sondern die darstellung des
propheten ist auch als bild also nicht
satirisch eigentlich verboten aber mich
in unserem kulturkreis verstehen ja
eigentlich diesen tabubruch gar nicht
für uns ist es ja gar kein und deshalb
finde ich die satire die ich ja
eigentlich für mein kulturkreis für
meine leser scharfmacher die die
benötigt eigentlich diese darstellung
nicht es gibt tausende andere
möglichkeiten um satire zu machen
hat jede zu machen zum thema des
fundamentalismus zum thema des
islamismus das ja auch wirklich
diskutiert werden muss also ob das
bilderverbot in vom koran her abgeleitet
werden kann das ist ja umstritten nicht
alle sehen das so
aber hersteller wie es ist denn beim
tages anzeiger haben sie mohammed
karikaturen mal gebracht nein aber nicht
gebracht nicht weil wir uns und dieses
bilderverbot gebunden fühlen nicht das
ist ein
ich denke wie sie gesagt haben ist das
ein wirklich weiß also wie es wörtlich
steht dann aus der geschichte heraus
dieses bild ist vermutlich ein verbot
damals gewesen gegen das kulturen der
größten religion nicht unter und wird
wird noch ob wir zum teil von von von
einzelnen sektoren noch sehr sehr ernst
genommen
wir haben uns deswegen nicht gezeigt
weil kein öl ins feuer gießen wollten in
einer in eine aktuelle sind ein sehr
konfliktreiche belastete beziehung
zwischen zwischen religionsgruppen nicht
und haben sie auch jetzt nicht gezeigt
haben jetzt sehr viel gezeigt unseren
lesern was charlie hebdo gemacht hat
auch zum thema islam
bei uns bewusst entschieden denn keine
keine karikaturen von mohammed zu zeigen
um nicht nur in diesen in diesen
konflikt
zusätzlich zu gießen oder sind
vielleicht zwei verschiedenen wegen oder
die frage welche restlichen tut man sich
selber auferlegen
und was soll ein objektiver standard
sein was satire da schon da bin ich
schon der meinung das ist ein
künstlerisches chance eigentlich und ich
finde die kunst soll eine sehr große
lizenz zur transgression haben also
kunst soll und satire soll unanständig
stellt anstoßen alles soll sie sein
dürfen
die gesellschaft braucht diese art der
auseinandersetzung mit irritierenden
formen des verhaltens mit abweichendem
verhalten dass das muss eine
gesellschaft einüben dass das geht nicht
und wie man das am besten macht ist
natürlich andere frage aber auch für das
gros der satire geld soll eine vielfalt
geben sollte und in spalten geben jetzt
eine position aber auch elektro soll es
geben mit seiner soll es geben dürften
mit einer position die hautpartien der
stroke anständige und alles mögliche das
muss das gehört zu einer freiheitlichen
gesellschaft ist aber auch so dass man
immer wieder sieht das nicht mit
gleichen ellen möglicherweise gemessen
wird zumindest kann man das beispiel
einbringen der papst karikatur die in
deutschland für viele aufruhr gesorgt
hat die technik hat eine karikatur
gebracht anlässlich von wikileaks 2012
das sieht man den papst mit einer
soutane die mit urin befleckt ist und
unten dran steht dann halleluja im
vatikan endlich ist das undichte leck
gefunden zu wikileaks und da der
deutsche presserat eine rüge
ausgesprochen
währenddessen man wenn man jetzt beginnt
mohammed karikaturen zu zensieren viele
leute finden warum das geht doch
eigentlich die freiheit der satire
also sind wir da wirklich bereit mit den
gleichen ellen zu messen
beim beispiel für titanic ist ist
vielleicht der ansatzpunkt ist aber
wirklich die persönlichkeitsverletzung
die mindestens im schweizer recht da
wirklich angeklagt werden könnte wären
was man lesen konnte natürlich eine
gottheit nicht als person verletzt
werden kann
da geht es um glaubensinhalte oder
glaubten symbole da gibt es ja auch ein
strafgesetz artikel dafür in der schweiz
ist das natürlich schon lange nicht mehr
angewandt worden so viel ich weiß das
heißt man die erste land in papst nicht
beleidigen seine person aber man war
dass man den eigenen das müsste ein
gericht entscheiden und außerhalb dieses
gerichtlich im rahmens ist das
tatsächlich meinungsfreiheit und soll
soll auch möglich sein
der presserat ist ja noch die eine eine
vorgeschaltete institution eben um
solche fälle in einem in einem medien
ethischen instanz zu vorzulegen und ich
denke die dürfte nicht
diese instanz sollte sich an diese
regeln halten wo es eine
persönlichkeitsverletzung ist da da ist
richtig wenn sie das feststellen ob ich
im übrigen biete dazu mit ihnen
einverstanden ich denke die satire muss
viel dürfen dass dort muss da dürfen die
grenze nicht eng sein sonst wird es
langweilig und wird jetzt auch nicht mit
ihren echten diskurs licht und in dem
sinne denke ich auch wenn wir sagen wir
zeigen die mohammed-karikatur nicht da
dies in einer zeit als einer aus einer
gesellschaftskritischen situation in
ihrem umfeld heraus aber wir würden
niemanden niemand ein der diese
karikatur zeigt nicht um diese ganze
kampagne jazz wie charlie hat ja auch
diesen wenig sagen diesen
verallgemeinerten effekt dass es nicht
mehr ein tabubruch jetzt ist dass es
damit auch nicht einzelne medien
exponiert das eigentlich sind war nicht
die frage ist welche gesellschaftlichen
auswirkungen hat es dann da sind wir
eher dafür dass der dialog zwischen den
religionen jetzt nicht mehr aus der
wertung solche zusätzlichen
konfliktpunkte nicht kann man sich dem
nur anschließen satire darf alles muss
aber nicht zu jedem zeitpunkt alles aus
spielen und das machen wir es hat
eigentlich auch immer einen ökonomischen
aspekte aus satire produzent zeichnet
kabarettist oder ein satiremagazin habe
am main publikum ich habe mein publikum
das ich dass das mich bezahlt indem ich
satire produzieren indem ich
gesellschaftskritische themen anspreche
und die in einem satirischen verfahren
so viele dass es unterhalten die ist
oder zumindest nachdenklich macht
einfach dass es gerne konsumiert wird
und da gibt es natürlich so viele
verschiedene zielgruppen die man
ansprechen kann dass man dass man die
ganze bandbreite offen lassen muss
satire per se solaris dürfen aber nicht
jeder muss das auch ausspielen wir
machen ja auch nicht täglich
auch wenn das satire freiheit wäre
karikaturen über magdeburg es gibt
dutzende tabu themen die wir nicht
ansprüche nur weil sie jetzt auch aus
native freiheit müssten angesprochen
werden
darf ich vielleicht nur noch ein punkt
doch widersprechen ich glaube alles darf
sie dann doch nicht satire das ist ja
auch nicht beispielsweise gegen die
schwächsten glieder der gesellschaft
verunglimpfen hetzerisch sei nicht das
denkt ist der grundsätzlich wenn man die
charlie hebdo karikaturen ansieht dann
waren sie vielleicht zum teil das deftig
zum teil auch nicht sehr sehr lustig was
weiß ich immer geschmackssache ist aber
sie waren nie verletzen oder hetzerisch
gegen gegen die schwächsten teile dieser
gesellschaft nicht das wenig denn ein
und darf satire nicht und das ist auch
der ursprung des satire die kommt von
unten nach oben geht
wo war ich das dann wieder immer
interessant findet im schweizerischen
diskurs in einem land oder einer
verfassung wo das volk wirklich viele
recht hat ist gerade nen unterschied zu
viel an drei festzustellen wir haben
nicht nur die möglichkeit wieder
angreifen wir müssen uns wirklich mit
unserem eigenen ohren für ihn
entscheiden oder auch richtigen zeit
befassen
und wenn ich dann auch manchmal dem
vorwurf höhere eeg macht die satire
nicht nur gegen oben dann stimmt das für
die schweiz eben auch nicht man muss
sagt jedoch gegen alle partizipierten
des gesetzes wegen des kurses machen
können und nicht gegen die schwächste
das ist klar aber im gegensatz zu vielen
anderen ländern und im gegensatz zur
geschichte der satire ist in der schweiz
hat das volk auch träger von entscheiden
die man diskutieren muss man muss den
souveränen kritisieren könnte und auch
qualifizieren können auch wenn er das
volk ist einfach schwieriger das volk zu
karl kellner seinen fürsten
aber ich möchte noch etwas hinzufügen
was mir wichtig sein guter humor oder
gute satire ist auch selbst bezüglich
also selbst ironie dass man sich selber
ab und zu auch aufs korn nehmen
denn die eben wichtiger so dass es nicht
nur gegen die anderen jetzt zum beispiel
eben gegen den islam ist und sagen dass
sieben
das haben sie ja auch angedeutet sollten
dann eben auch entsprechende karikaturen
gegen alle möglichen regierung gegen die
eigene und vielleicht sogar sollte sich
eine
tages in der redaktion auch mal selber
aufs korn nehmen satirisch also die
besten humoristen sind wirklich die auch
die zu feinsinniger selbstironie fähig
sind dann sind sie auch ein
glaubwürdigsten glaube ich jetzt
scheinen sie sich alle einig zu sagen
grundsätzlich darf satire alles sie muss
vielleicht nicht alles aber dann ist es
immer noch so einen mit geschmacksfrage
was ist mit dem französischen komiker
dieudonné der eine art hitlergruß zu
seinem markenzeichen gemacht hat und der
antisemitische parolen verbreitet hätten
sie das auch noch im bereich dessen was
man so machen darf es gibt wirklich
diese grauzonen was enorm schwierig ist
das zu hören ich kenne jetzt ich kenne
die person natürlich auch aus der presse
aber ich habe es ist wirklich eine
schwierigkeit die kenne ich auch aus der
karikaturisten oder um eine
beschäftigung auch vorher mal
wissenschaftliche mit karikatur die
mittel der karikatur einsetzt oder
satire an sich das ist ja ein
baukastenprinzip mit mit bildern mit
stereotypen die man verwendet neu
kombiniert und wenn man sich das allein
vom formal anschaut dann ist das nichts
anderes als auch stürmer propaganda oder
einfach propaganda kommunistische
propaganda die eingesetzt worden ist die
bildsprache die aussage sprache ist ist
eigentlich nicht zu unterscheiden von
karikaturen wie müssen wieder sein vom
handwerk hergehen macht natürlich ist
der standpunkt der hintere treten wird
entscheiden und da ist es eigentlich
tatsächlich enorm schwierig zu sagen wie
sich nicht weiter das muss halt auch
wirklich immer wieder aufs neue
diskutiert werden
das ist nicht der exakte wissenschaft
doch man kann es an das darf man das
auch noch nicht ich glaube es ist
wirklich immer wieder die rezipienten
schafft die empfänger solcher satire die
entscheiden muss darf das sein und mit
der nicht was missbraucht im im gewande
von satire vielleicht ein werk sagen ein
tabubruch haben sich ist noch nicht satt
ihren nicht das ist da fällt der spd
hält
ein gedanke dahinter und das denke ich
für den hitler gruß gilt für die für die
abbildung und von mohammed es ist an
sich der tabubruch noch nicht die satire
nicht mit dieser tiere müssten eine eine
idee haben dann bekommt sie häufig auch
eine richtung nicht und deshalb
erscheint dieser gedanke recht
interessant zu sein
eine eine satire die muss in der tendenz
auch von unten nach oben gehen
vielleicht ist zum teil dann auch in der
schweiz brauchen eine mehrheit des
volkes vielleicht oben nicht das könnte
auch eine definition sein und gefährlich
wird sagen wenn sie ihn auch nach unten
zielt bei bonn es ist mein eindruck ist
ein programm zielt auf die auf die auf
die migranten in seinem land in
frankreich und ist damit eine häufig
daran der verunglimpfung an der hetze
nicht und das war das war die frage die
sich die schweiz stellte außerdem ein
programm zeigen gezeigt hat darf man
jetzt lieber entschieden ich denke das
wird noch ein bisschen abhängig vom von
vom klima ich denke in der schweiz ist
soll das möglich sein dass ein jude
töten in sein programm zeigt aber
letztlich der gesamtkontext ist eine
form von von hetze und nach unten treten
wir gegen migranten nicht
jetzt kann man natürlich auch wenn man
sich da vielleicht auf glatteis begibt
aber ich denke man muss über diese
themen diskutieren kann man auch sagen
eigentlich sind auch die mohammed
karikaturen in frankreich ein bisschen
vielleicht eintreten nach unten weil wir
diese schwierigkeit haben dass die
kolonialgeschichte in frankreich ein
stück weit nach wie vor nicht wirklich
verschmerzt wurde nicht wirklich
verwunden wurde wir haben immer noch
eine sehr starke segregation
wir haben im vorfeld dieses gesprächs
auch mit berna gesprochen er ist
französischer auto schriftsteller
ursprünglich aber jura cia und leitet
sein programm berater auch bei arte und
er bringt beispielsweise den die
vorstellung so das bild das er sagt der
mann in die bonus geht sieht man 95
prozent der kinder die fußball spielen
auch in den nachwuchs clubs sind
schwarze schwarz heutige kinder
dunkelhäutige kinder material
einwanderer kinder wenn man guckt wer
ist in den leitungsfunktionen des
französischen fußballs 0 prozent also
alles weiß
und er sagt im grunde genommen ist das
einfach ein skandal und sehr sehr viele
dieser einwanderung das ist der
springende punkt haben eben einen
hintergrund muslimischer muslimischen
glaubens also stimmt dieses bild dann
wirklich dass man sagt auch diese satire
charlie hebdo war eintreten von unten
nach oben ich sehe das so ich glaube die
der schall lebt da hat er nicht in seine
karikaturen gegen diese islamischen
migranten gemacht sondern gegen wie
dogmatiker in dieser in dieser religion
nicht die mit einem ganz bestimmten
politischen und fundamentale religiösen
anspruch jetzt besuchten versuchen eben
einfluss zu nehmen auch die sektoren
nicht
deshalb hat sich also ich hab jetzt
keine karikatur gesehen die sich lustig
gemacht hat über über über die braune
soße die oder die moslems sind in den
portalen mir das nicht eintrete sei
nicht was gelernt haben ist durch
trotzdem richtig nicht diese
gesellschaftliche unterrichtung diese
zum teil sehr mangelhafte integration
mit fehlenden perspektiven
das erklärt dann aber er hat eigentlich
den politischen hintergrund zurück oder
solcher taten jetzt eher nicht von von
von jungen männern zweiter generation
mit enttäuschten ambitionen nicht ohne
ohne jede form von politischen kompass
und mitgefühl und soweit ich denke das
wäre er da ein erklärungsansatz in diese
richtung über das auch so sehen also
wenn wir das gesamte die total von
reaktor- anschaut dann ist es eher
bissige gesellschaftskritik in
frankreich gegen vor allem auch gegen
eben die die spitze des staates gegen
die art und weise wie der staat geführt
würden die politiker sich verhalten es
ist wirklich eine umfassende bissige
gesellschaftskritik diaz ich jetzt nicht
eingeschossen hat auf die boni bewohner
das würde ich auch so sehen also
mindestens so immer arbeitet seit kurzem
gezeigt
strauss-kahn ist immer wieder ein thema
und das täglich also ich denke das sehe
ich jetzt nicht dass ausgefahren nicht
unendlich houellebecqs als szenario der
einzelheiten würden würde was wir nicht
glauben dann könnte man über
die frage wieder diskutieren ob da eben
heute eigentlich doch interessant ist
die also es ist nicht direkt connected
aber es gibt ja die verbindungen kann
man es doch ein bisschen nachvollziehen
es geht nicht gegen die spanier aber es
geht es trifft ihn bauen hier eine
gruppe die sich als sehr stark mit
dieser mit dem islam identifiziert und
wenn man weiterschauen will und sich
überlegt wie wir können wir europa
sicherer machen muss man ja auch da
ansetzen
man muss und den unteren schichten in
frankreich den zugewandert und
wahrscheinlich einfach andere
perspektiven vermitteln dass der islam
nicht zum zentralen lebensinhalt wird
oder diese auslegung des islam zum
lustigen er korrekt zu sagen was ist
denn eigentlich los in frankreich das
ist ja auch eine schwierige frage wenn
wir nach frankreich blicken es gibt
wenig andere länder in europa die eine
so starke militant islamistischen szene
habe man weiß auch dass das größte
kontingent an kämpfern in syrien jetzt
europäischer kämpfer stammt aus
frankreich wie ist es zu dieser zu
dieser problematik gekommen in
frankreich also man sagt schon dass es
natürlich eine eine mangelnde
integration ist also dass das eine
ghettoisierung hat stattfinden können
man hat ausweis nicht auf welchen
gründen aus schlechtem gewissen auch
über den kolonialismus haben uns sehr
viele leute reingelassen hat ihn aber
überhaupt keine perspektive geboten hat
sie eher ausgegrenzt gesellschaftlich
zum teil auch mit sozialbau die quasi
ghettoisierung zum zum zur folge gehabt
nicht wahr und dann keine entsprechenden
beruflichen perspektiven geboten hat
also all das wird gesagt über frankreich
zeige ich ein riesen integrationsproblem
vorhanden ist so viel größer ist als in
london kann ich selber nicht nicht
beurteilen aber ich glaube schon dass
also frankreich hat bestimmt ein
integrationsproblem man sollte
allerdings immer mit erklärungen
vorsichtig sein ich war was genau war es
auslöst in einer gesellschaft das ist
kompliziert das ist ja jetzt voreilig zu
sagen das massaker ist im grunde
genommen
als resultat eines integrationsproblems
das wäre zu kurz gegriffen natürlich ich
denke oder mindesten
müsste man das sehr viel breiter
abgestützt sagen und wenn ihr
zurückkommen noch einmal auf die
mohammed-karikaturen
sie haben ja vorhin betont es gibt zwar
die möglichkeit auf hat ihr alles darf
aber sie soll nicht alles sie haben auch
vom vielleicht gutem geschmack
gesprochen
sie haben aber in ihren platz auch den
andreas team engagiert der ja nun
wirklich eine person ist die moment in
der schweizer stark polarisiert und
nicht gerade eben mit samthandschuhen an
die sache rangeht sondern auch sehr sehr
islam kritisch vorgibt
ist das nicht ein widerspruch also
andreas ihle hat bei uns bis jetzt noch
keine mohammed karikaturen gezeichnet
obwohl er auch bei uns zeichnet
widerspruch ist es nicht weil ich denke
wir machen ja ebene diverse spielarten
konstatiere wenn man andreas thiel ist
ja nicht als satiriker ist ja nicht den
haudegen gewesen für mich sondern
wirklich ein brillanter denker der mal
von der anderen seite denke das ist es
tatsächlich auch von mir gewohnt
gesuchten ein kabarettist der nicht
links steht von dem man weiß dass er
nicht links steht und der in einem land
das er nun doch nicht nur bürgerlich
regiert ist sondern eher concorde andre
gierth ist ist es eine stimme die ich
sehr schätze die halter themen aufgreift
von der anderen seite her betrachtet wir
haben eigentlich nur ihn und so ist er
ganz im sinne einer forums zeitschrift
auch einfach eine stimme die die wir im
blatt haben möchten und weiterhin haben
möchten
bei uns macht ja wahrscheinlich auch
keine streitschriften ich denke sie
wissen nicht ganz vergleichbar weil er
ist ja nicht aussortiert in diesem
zusammenhang hatte sich exponiert also
tatsächlich denke ich die toilette hat
diese jetzt erlebt haben
er hat sich jetzt exponiert aus koran
experte nicht und das auf 1 11 denke ich
nicht sonderlich aus meiner sicht nicht
sonderlich überzeugende art teilen koran
letztlich nur verstehen kann im
historischen kontext in seiner ganzen
komplexität das also ich würde ihn jetzt
das aus kabarettisten würde ich ihnen
denken
nach wie vor als als durchaus
erfolgreich halten aber nicht unbedingt
das aus koran xi geht bei dem vater im
punkt finde ich dennoch interessant dass
man dass man jetzt hingeht und behauptet
für den koran zu verstehen und sich über
den neuesten muss man ein studium
vorweisen ein längeres dass der staat
für die meisten und muslime auch nicht
zu weil das habe ich nicht mehr haben ja
auch der gemäßigte der komplexität des
korans zumindest in zwei dimensionen
bewusstsein dass ein ist die die
historische dimension versuchen das was
gesagt wurde in dieser historischen
dimension zu erklären und das zweite mal
muss hinaus steinbruchsee nicht ich kann
ich kann mit dem alten testament eine
eigentliche beweis warum auch in videos
wie das team mit dem koran ich kann aber
auch auf stellensuche nicht und ich
meine wenn vorträgen über die
integration geredet haben man müsste man
annehmen dass zum teil gemacht aber es
wäre interessant das noch genau zu
machen
wie viele maschinen beispielsweise
durchaus eine integrationspolitisch
wichtige rolle spielen in verschiedenen
ländern wenig power label beispielsweise
vermutlich in frankreich das müsste man
es genau sehen auch in der schweiz
beispielsweise auch denke die die
meisten moscheen in der in der schweiz
sieht kommt durchaus eine eine wichtige
gemeinschafts bildende und und durchaus
auch integrations bildende funktion
nicht es gibt natürlich auch andere
nicht das ist klar auf diesen dann nicht
mehr in den schlagzeilen deshalb
vergisst man häufig was daneben noch
eine arbeit gemacht
es geht auch weiter zurück die
geschichte bis zu sondern rasch die
mindestens japanischen börsen und der
fatwa gegen ihn und gegen alle die mit
der publikation des buches etwas zu tun
haben es gab den mördern japanischen
übersetzt
ich denke was rasch die eigentlich
wolltest eine eine debatte über die
auslegung des korans nicht was da auf
wörtlich da steht das steht auch in der
bibel ist neben ganz viele schreckliche
dinge wörtlich dem alten testament es
das aber gibt gibt es eine allegorische
symbolische auslegung oder wird das
wörtlich ausgelegt diese debatte ist
wichtig oder und da kann man nicht
einfach hingehen und texte lesen und
zitieren
die frage ist wie wir das ausgelegt wie
wird das gepredigt was machen die imams
damit wie bringen sich den leuten näher
dass das ist richtig ist aber auch dass
tiefe gegangen 30 jahre seit seinem
anlass das japanischen für also
eigentlich in dieser hinsicht nicht
wirklich viel bewegt haben das ist die
enttäuschung der artikel aus der zeit
online
ich weiß nicht von herrn bittner der
jetzt einfach auf sagte den islam fehlt
immer noch die europäische aufklärung
das macht ihn halt so humor resistent ob
man da das ist natürlich ein riesen ding
wie wie kann man da etwas ändern dass er
interessant ein ich denke auch bei der
bei den jetzigen attentaten in dieser
woche das eigentlich ist auch die
tatsächlich mindestens so stark gegen
diese versuche richtet geht diese
kulturen und gesellschaften zu
öffentlichen dieser dimension eigentlich
von größerer tragweite noch ist denn
genau dieser prozess ist ja eine in
vielen islamischen gesellschaften jetzt
im raum und rund und auseinandersetzung
punkt wirklich große auseinandersetzung
nicht das ist natürlich auch ein stück
weit ein bisschen ein pauschalisieren
das urteil oder zusagen den islam fehlt
eigentlich immer noch die aufklärung es
gibt auch die bewegung für einen
fortschrittlichen islam die sehen das
anders versuchen die sachen anders
darzustellen plädieren auch dafür in
einer toleranten sichtweise eben
vielleicht unterschiedliche
ausdrucksformen von aufklärerischem
gedankengut gelten zu lassen was ich
denke es wichtig daher auch
unterscheidungen zu treffen mit lawrow
ist ja letztlich also werden sie noch
genau wissen aber letztlich auch und
dünner firmen ist in der
kulturgeschichte nicht vor kanada haben
das sagen haben das schon festgestellt
mit der ganzen was in der
kulturindustrie passiert houellebecq
wenn ich ihn doch mal hier zitieren kann
ja gesagt ich zweifele an der aufklärung
ist sie eine volksauto also dass auch
die aufklärung ist auch in talent
westlichen und christlichen kultur ja
immer wieder massiv bedroht und in frage
gestellt
das ist wirklich das schlimmste was
jetzt passieren kann dass man dass man
einfach das so auseinanderdividiert ein
ein aufgeklärter westen
wir haben jetzt ja schon gesehen das
stimmt ja auch nicht wir haben auch
unsere videos durch in unserem eigenen
diskursen und dort ein rückständiges
land das stimmt das bild ist natürlich
viel viele weitere facetten also sich
dann darstellt und genau das ist die
gefahr dass man sich jetzt da in einen
dualismus hineinsteigert die geschichte
der meinungsäusserungsfreiheit ist ja
tatsächlich auch eng verwoben mit der
aufklärung denken die haben wollte ja
beispielsweise in frankreich eine ganz
wichtige figur für dieses thema jetzt
kochen ja alle auf diese
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit und man sagt
das ist der große wert des westens
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit muss
unbedingt gelten
ich habe mir da zwischen die augen und
ich weiß nicht ob ich das zu unrecht tue
aber wir haben in der schweiz seit 1994
eine anti rassismus strafnorm und just
die jenigen die vehemenz dafür waren
sind jetzt diejenigen die sagen wir
brauchen mehr meinungsfreiheit also wie
geht das zusammen fragt sich schöne war
ja in der tat eine eine sehr schwierige
frage ich denke manchmal zu rückgang
dogville der in seinem buch über die
demokratin amerikanern mit also unter 30
jahren des 19 jahrhunderts
das beschreibt in den usa sagt seltsame
situation rechtlich ist fast alles ja
überhaupt ich man darf alles sagen es
gibt keine herrscher mehr die einem
verformten politisch aber sozial wird
man sofort geächtet für bestimmte
aussagen oder und ich glaube
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit in eine
gesellschaft ist eine komponente von
zwei dingen leben was ist rechtlich
erlaubt und was wird sofort sozial
geächtet wird jemand sofort ausgegrenzt
für bestimmte aussagen und deshalb das
ist ja auch ihr anliegen
und ich glaube dass auch deshalb ist
auch charlene so wichtig dass es gibt
dort weniger darum dass rechtlich
erlaubte nicht zu tun oder zu tun
sondern eigentlich das sozial anstößige
aufs parkett zu bringen und der
gesellschaft den spiegel vorzuhalten und
zu sagen da schaut mal wie intolerant
eigentlich die gesellschaft ist nicht
weil sie bestimmte dinge verbieten
rechtlich sondern weil sie sofort
abweichendes verhalten arbeitendes reden
errichteten ich war sozial ächtet und
ich glaube es ist eine komponente von
beiden jetzt mit der rassismusstrafnorm
glaube ich hat man versucht die
erodierende vielleicht die rotierende
soziale ächtung zu kompensieren durch
das recht ich war also dass ich in einer
normalen gesellschaft sagen die leute
einander du das wirklich unanständig das
sagt man doch nicht eine beleidigung und
bitte entschuldigt man kommt so wieder
miteinander ins benehmen wenn solche
sozialen dynamiken wegfallen dann
springen die leute zum richter um
irgendwie irre beleidigung zu einer
medium dagegen zu finden und das ist das
halte ich für falsch und ich glaube auch
mit dieser rassismus strafnorm ist es
ähnliches welches auch einen
verlegenheiten ich war wir wissen gar
nicht mehr genau wie wir die leute zum
anstand bringen im normalen
gesellschaftlich gespräch und dann
greifen wir zum recht und ich frage mich
ob es nicht auch kontraproduktiv ist
nicht das ist wenn es einfach rechtlich
verboten ist
dann wird das quasi in die illegalität
verdrängt nicht warten
wir sind dieser rassen optimal irgendwo
und sie können sich nicht richtig äußern
dann kann man auch nicht darauf
antworten man kann die leute auch nicht
herausfordern bei diesen dingen also ich
glaube schon dass jede gesellschaft
insbesondere auch die demokratische das
hat doch viel wirklich gezeigt jede
insbesondere demokratische gesellschaft
die hat eine bestimmte gefahr so einen
engen sozialen mainstream zu haben und
dann sofort leute als fremde wie talk
wie gesagt man wird dann sofort man hier
zwar nicht rechtlich bestraft damit
sofort als fremdling ausgegrenzt wenn
man bestimmte dinge sagt nicht also sie
sehen durchaus an dieser antirassismus
strafnorm gewisse kritische punkte würde
nicht so weit gehen dass das wahnsinn so
weit würde ich nicht gehen aber die eben
wie sollte die debatte offen bleiben ob
das wirklich
die richtige art und weise ist mit dem
umzugehen also eben in den usa gibt es
solche strafnormen nicht aber man kann
vom doppel lernen dass es ganz andere
formen der sozialen ächtung dafür gibt
und vielleicht ist es besser wenn eine
gesellschaft hat ihr also nicht
rechtlich sondern rein gesellschaftliche
umgangsformen hat wo sie mit solchen
beleidigenden herabsetzenden skandalösen
aussagen umzugehen weiß ohne dass dafür
wie die gerichte angerufen werden müssen
das könnte jetzt der wert sein der der
kommentarspalten in den in den
online-foren nicht sehr viel lacht
deftiges gesagt wird ja nach daran bei
uns der relativen liberales verhält ist
dazu immer im raum dass das eben solche
schranken wie sie jetzt der rassismus
strafversetzt nicht und dabei habe ich
habe mich sehr interessant von ihnen
jetzt hören was sie saugen schon vor der
dame aber dieses diese mit der philosoph
sie diese dieses erste strafecke das
dazu hört aber ich glaube die die die
schranken zu setzen wenn sie wenn sie
nicht tief sie sollten einigermaßen hoch
sein als sollte wirklich im öffentlichen
diskurs eine eine herabsetzende über die
hdmi oder rasse definiert der absetzung
stattfinden die geeignet ist wieder eben
eigentlich wie wird diskutiert haben die
mohammed karikaturen in einem feuer zu
gießen in offene wunden in einer
eines kollektiven erinnerung gefühl es
nicht er weiß zufällig wie auf diese
haben die rassismusstrafnorm schon zum
einsatz gekommen gab es ja bekanntlich
ganz wegen kann es wenn ich jetzt dann
genau vor jahresfrist war die letzte
diskussion und da ging es ja auch wieder
zentral und humor und satire um
kabarettisten und auch fernsehbeiträge
und da stehen wir schon die nachfrage
hat man mich mit zwei ellen gemessen
beim jetzt alle von meinungsfreiheit
sprechen und in einem anderen diskurs
umfeld haben auch die kommentatoren
schweiz weil natürlich das ganz anders
beurteilt auf dem hintergrund dieser
strafen und insofern eine rückfrage eben
gibt es hier ein heuchlerisches moment
auch wenn man das in diesen in diesen
tagen so sagen darf aber das wurde in
gewissen kommentaren war das jetzt auch
zu lesen dieser vorwurf macht sich eine
gewisse ratlosigkeit breit merke ich
aber grundsätzlich kann ja schon die
frage stellen wieso haben die ja eine
anti rassismus strafen raum ich merke
jetzt von ihnen einen gewissen
widerspruch ich weiß nicht wie kritisch
die herrscht rede diese antirassismus
strafnorm beurteilen und gleichzeitig
sagen dir jetzt alle meinungsfreiheit
das ist so ein hohes gut das dürfen wir
nicht aufgeben ist so ganz zentrales gut
des westens wenn also meine haltung ist
eben genau weil dieser öffentliche
diskurs so wichtig ist nicht nur da auch
viel möglich sein sollen in widerspruch
in auch zum teil nicht die nicht nur in
den sattesten trainer diskutiert werden
soll wie wir selber online foren
feststellen soll es gewisse grenzen
geben nicht die sie dürfen einfach nicht
zu eigen seien nicht dass und vor allem
nachdenke bei ihm im raum der satire
wenn wir wenn wir die satire so
verstehen wir dass vorne gemacht haben
dass sie nicht nach unten zielt nicht
hetzerisch ist dann soll bei etwa der
satire sehr sehr viel möglich sei nicht
und da darf nicht allein rassismus
straftäter vorgaben machen das wäre dann
wir
das ende des deshalb ist dieses
diskurses nicht der humor gleich kommen
ja noch danach darauf der humor hat er
genau diese funktion einen
gesellschaftlichen konflikt vor augen
wenn danach mit selbstironie noch
verbunden ist im gesellschaftlichen
konflikte ihnen aufzuweichen sich sie
sich selber wenig gewicht zunehmen
glaubt weniger wichtig zu nehmen damit
einer einheitlichen ist ein sehr diskurs
fördern das mittel das passt mir
probleme als mit der rassismusstrafnorm
habe ich also ganz entschieden mit mit
diesen persönlichkeitsschutz das klingt
zwar sehr gut nicht wahr aber also in
der philosophischen
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit erwarte gibt
es dieses know how do you know how also
dass schädigung prinzip also liefern
schädigen also keine rechte sollen
verletzt werden aber dann gibt es auch
dieses beleidigungs prinzip ich war man
es auch niemanden beleidigen und in der
ähre verletzten und das geht mir
eigentlich zu weit ich finde ich seh
nicht gerade zahlen bislang man nicht
beleidigt werden soll
das kann ja wenn die beleidigung nämlich
nicht zutrifft dann kann man ja sagen
okay wir prüfen das ist der rat stimmt
und meistens fällt das er zurück auch
zurück auf den beleidiger wenn der
irgendeine beleidigung ausspricht die
eklatant nicht stimmt also dass man das
vom recht her lenken soll dann jeder zum
richter springt her ich bin beleidigt
worden ich war natürlich braucht es auch
dort und es gibt im bundesdeutschen
bundesverfassungsgericht hat die
ehrverletzung in deutschland es wichtig
aber die die us präsenz ist respektiv
das gebe ich zu aber schon nur die
tatsache dass das immer recht dass das
eine beleidigung rechtlich geahndet
werden soll dass das widerstrebt mir
muss ich sagen die leute sorgen nicht
beleidigen in der öffentlichkeit mehr
verbreiten sind schlecht amis araber
professor ja das war dann sagt sie das
hart wenn es stimmt stimmt zu und jetzt
nicht stimmt dann sollte heute in die
vorlesung kommt sich ein eigenes bild
machen also dass ich dann zum richter
springer bitte sehe ich bin beleidigt
worden in meiner ehre das leuchtet mir
nicht ein also zu einer freiheitlichen
gesellschaft gehört schon dass man sich
auch an den karren fahren darf und muss
man sich auch beleidigen darf dass das
sehe ich nicht ein da geht meines
erachtens die europäische rechtsprechung
viel zu wenig war verleumdung ist was
anderes
auch materielle der kein moralist war
hat gesagt verleumdung ist gift für die
republik da kann ich nämlich irgendeinen
eines verbrechens beschuldigen um ihn
loszuwerden nicht wahr
also wer verleumdet haben die beweislast
der muss mindestens belegen können dass
es stimmt nicht dass leuchte mehr ein
aber so eine beleidigung herabsetzung ja
so wenn jemand mir ein verbrechen
vorwerfen ich war in der öffentlichkeit
nicht begangen habe dann bietet er
musste in der das tut der muss das der
muss das beweisen dass da hat auch
materiell lisa war eine moralische
schranke in der republik gesetzt oder
also verleumdung ist wirklich gift für
die republik da kann man den
ökonomischen oder politischen gegner
kann einfach loswerden durch verleumder
das ist das ist schlecht da eine
gesellschaft zu ende gedacht wäre das ja
nicht die karikatur womöglich in meinen
die witzigen logische einer karikatur
ist ja nicht ein schmäh bild mann hat
bereits mit laut ria also eigentlich
schon in der antike einfach die gesichts
karikatur in denen hässlich macht ist
das eine form von schwäche
von einer beleidigung es hat auch sogar
vergleiche zum schadens aber man macht
halt auf dem papier das was man mit
einer person macht möglich und das ist
letztlich die wurzel der karikatur und
eines wichtigen partie also ja man kann
sich ja nicht so weit gehen
das stimmt natürlich dass sich niemand
auch keine karikaturen von sich selber
oder das ist denke ich mir nicht
gefallen was sie gesagt haben dass
beleidigung nicht nicht richtig
funktionieren sollte würde uns das leben
auch ziemlich viel einfacher auch ein
übriges
wobei ich da war ich doch noch aus indem
sie ihnen denke ich präzisieren möchte
nur wenn einer sagt designer schlechter
professor dass er ein werturteil das
lässt sich nicht an glauben nicht und
das ist eine tendenz in die kritiker
freiheit in sanaa
nicht die offenen werde dann dass es
noch irgendwie belegt wird mit mit
indizien sonst ist es nicht aber an sich
denke ich ist der geht es über also über
über die die verunglimpfung hinaus durch
falsche fakten wenn ich das wirklich
sehr massiv ist in form der beleidigung
dann wenig ist es durchaus vernünftig
nach dem gesellschaftlichen diskurs eine
grenze zu setzen einfach deswegen weil
die medien natürlich sehr stark sind
sehr sehr weit verbreitet sind weil wir
sehen dass es das medien opfer syndrom
eben auch gibt eigentlich wie die
menschen anders dramatisierten wenn sie
haben zum teil auch durch beleidigungen
stehen ja also wir haben wir haben denn
wir waren beispielsweise der weltwoche
nicht und kann sagen da geht es um die
fakten stimmen die fakten oder nicht
aber häufig sind ja so viele geschichten
da noch angereichert mit
verunglimpfungen jetzt auch dass das des
akademischen leistungsnachweises der
betroffene person
ich sage den ich denke ich das geht dann
den den beteiligten schon in den bereich
über wo tatsächlich dass das
persönlichkeitsrecht tangiert
aber gerade das ist ja eines thilo
sarrazin erwähnt den ich ein gutes
beispiel finde weil er hat ja dieses
buch geschrieben deutschland schafft
sich ab dass wurde groß dann auch in der
schweiz diskutiert und das nächste buch
hieß ja dann der tugendterror und da hat
er genau diese täter aufgenommen die sie
froh hinein nicht geziert haben aber
eigentlich von der anderen richtung her
also sie haben ja gesagt die menschen
getrauen sich heute nicht mehr in einer
freiheitlichen gesellschaft sich die
meinung zu sagen also schreien sie nach
dem recht sie waren dann zum richter
einen paragraphen haben auf die sich
berufen können er hat eigentlich gesagt
der tugendterror ist so gestrickt dass
sie alle einander dauernd den mund
verbieten hat eigentlich keine
meinungsfreiheit keine redefreiheit mehr
dauernd kommt jemand moralinsauer daher
und verbietet einem den mund hatte damit
doch vielleicht den nerv der zeit
getroffen
die schmunzeln ich denke da an den tweet
von durch leute hat den rauch
breit diskutiert worden ist im anschluss
und wenn sie dann auch korrigiert hat
aber tugendterror die empörungswelle die
jetzt in den sozialen medien über diesen
tweet los genau als einstieg man hat er
in einem tweet 140 zeichen zur verfügung
und man möchte sich zu diesen taten man
muss nicht lange darüber diskutieren
vielleicht ist dass es nicht der beste
einstieg in eine stellungnahme gewesen
ich habe dann aber wirklich jetzt auch
die letzten tage beobachtet man spricht
jetzt über diesen tweet und es ist auch
wieder eine empörungswelle im gang die
nicht ab obwohl sie sich eigentlich
wenige ich eine stunde später dann schon
entschuldigt hat für diese tugend terror
ein bisschen gehört das sicher auch
fortan zu den sozialen medien dass das
tat beschützt uns die daten von dem er
denke ich dass diese kontrollfunktion
der gesellschaft jenseits der gesetze
und rechte die gibt es ja eigentlich
doch oder sie ist wieder im kommen in
anderem kontext genau das was dogville
gemeint hat oder sofort eine soziale
ächtung eine welle der empörung gegen
jemand der irgendwann das aber anders
gesagt hat was in dem moment für
unpassend gehalten werden ich war es ist
eine ironie der geschichte dass jetzt
gerade an diesen tweet der bundesrätin
leuthard man eigentlich wiederum
vorgesetzt bekommt wie es mit der
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit steht oder
das dass sie das nicht hätte schreiben
sollen das ist ja ist ja ihr recht das
zu schreiben wenn es meinungsäußerung
neue denke ich denke vielleicht war es
ja um passen nicht was wenn es das ist
möglich ich persönlich denke es ist ja
es war unpassend weil sie natürlich mit
dieser aussage im prinzip ist ja sache
richtig aber in diesem kontext gesagt
macht sie die opfer eine spur
mitverantwortlich würde das was passiert
ist nicht damit täglich es ist wahr sie
unpassend aber das ist nicht das
passiert jeden von uns einig dass wir
umfassend äußerungen machen da ist im
ernst natürlich dann teil ist dieses
kurses darüber zu reden da kommen sie
sagen okay vielleicht waren fehler oder
ich hab es nicht so gemeint
und dann kann ich daraus was
was vernünftiges einstehen nicht ich
werde jetzt sagen wenn jemand dann fest
genau geklärt oder aufgrund dieses déi
zwee sage okay leute hat und passen sie
verteidigt eben doch man darf nicht über
über satire darf nicht über religion
gemacht werden weil die cvp ist und das
wäre dann überinterpretation nicht aber
grundsätzlich mal im moment zu sagen
das halte ich jetzt verpasse nicht dass
die legitimen teile ist es ihre ihres
anspruchs auf einen öffentlichen diskurs
in die rede und gegenrede sehr wichtig
also dass man lernt ja auch noch etwas
wenn man etwas sagt und dann etwas
geantwortet bekommt ich heute davon lebt
ja streitkultur ist wichtig
wahrscheinlich gerade auch etwas was wir
in der schweiz zu beiden bisschen mehr
pflegen könnten nicht in drei dinge
manchmal auch da die augen wenn man
vergleicht mit der art der sortiere die
in deutschland möglich ist dann denke
ich mal gehen der schweiz könnten noch
einzulegen aber das ist wahrscheinlich
ein anderes thema blicken die in die
zukunft aber vielleicht warum mich das
ist ein wunder dass wir beispielsweise
selten auch nicht also tier ist eine der
schwierigsten fordern die es überhaupt
gibt ihn in der öffentlichen
meinungsäußerungen und jahren schon
richtig nachmittag nicht und häufig die
gelingt vielleicht dass es jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen streng aber sie
gelingt vielleicht ihn so richtig gut in
einem von drei fällen nicht und da sehen
wir jetzt besser bei charlie hebdo er
wird zum teil neben speisen nach bei uns
wenn satire gemacht und deshalb sind
häufig die medien noch relativ
zurückhaltend mit satire nicht nur weil
ich da jetzt auch noch gerne an füge der
vergleich zu deutschland oder anderen
satire kultur mit ländern ich sage auch
in eine gesellschaft hat diese dieser
tiere die sie verdient und wir haben
natürlich auch ganz anderes politisches
system und die satire kultur
widerspiegelt eigentlich auch den
öffentlichen diskurs mit vernehmlassung
demokratie mit der konkordanz die die
entscheider in politik und wirtschaft
die sind ja ganz anders eingebunden das
volk selbst ist anders eingebunden und
ich finde einfach das führt zu einer
anderen satire kultury ist nicht die ist
natürlich anders
aber es ist nicht schlecht das ist
einfach wahrscheinlich so viel subtiler
und anders formuliert wie eben auch die
die diskussionskultur in der politik
selbst auch noch ist auch nach wie vor
international halten
niemals einem und ein deutschen
bundestags im schlagabtausch das blicken
wir noch in die zukunft welche
auswirkungen wird das massaker haben
denken sie die spannungen zwischen der
westlichen und der islamischen welt
werden sich weiter verschärfen was ich
mein erster eindruck ist aufgrund der
reaktion ist dass es nicht nicht zu
einer verschärfung führt nicht aufgrund
des relativ noch noch bis jetzt
vernünftigen des kurses denke dass auch
nicht geformt jetzt ist der westen gegen
gegen gegen den islam oder gegen noch
schlimmer gegen irgendeine migranten in
ihm im westen sondern dass es eher eine
eine besinnung jetzt was zur folge hat
dass die medien auf eine gute art
zusammengerückt sind eben gesagt haben
wir lassen uns nicht einschüchtern
endlich auch gut dass es vielleicht auch
ein bisschen jetzt durch diesen
nachdruck der rics medien in aller welt
gemacht wurde ein bisschen normal wird
auch über religion eben karikaturen zu
zeigen dass er meine hoffnung ist die
große gefahr dass wenn sie darauf
ansprechen probiert sich der konflikt
verschärfen
die stillose konflikt verschärfen wird
in diesen kulturen stattfinden jahren an
den rändern ist dass der beiden kulturen
statt wie in den arabischen ländern
dass er sich tatsächlich sehe ich nicht
wie die konfrontation in den nächsten
jahren sich entspannen sollte nicht ich
glaube auch dass ich dass dieses eine
tragische massa kann man sich jetzt
nicht mehr viele gibt wegstecken wenn es
da ist die reaktion ist richtig gewesen
von fast allen seiten einfach mit der
hoffnung dass es nicht noch zu weiteren
taten kommt oder zu machen staaten dann
würde sich möglicherweise doch das
display sieht man mal dann das
unsicherheitsgefühl doch um sich
greifende in frankreich vielleicht in
anderen nehmen
aber wenn wir das jetzt so verarbeiten
können so tragisch und das leben das ist
die symbolische aktion dass dahinter
stehen sind der meinungsfreiheit so
stark ist jetzt abgelaufen ist die
gibt's dann hatte eben auch nur einmal
denke ich und wenn sich jetzt weitere
solche attentate ereignen würde würde
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr gleich hier
deshalb ist doch ein bisschen ein
unwohlsein bei mir vorhanden wenn es
meist die hitlisten diskus richtig
lenken können auch und ihn auch nicht so
schnell wieder ad acta legen das ist der
ganz wichtig dann überstehen wir das
auch unbeschadet aber der das ganze
ochsen tat fällt ja doch auch in eine
zeitung und sagen muss der diskurs hat
sich bereits verschärft denken wir an
die bewegung peggy da in deutschland die
uns irgendwie auch aufrüttelt es wurde
auch gerade diese woche ein neues ein
neuer bericht des religionsmonitor der
bertelsmann stiftung veröffentlicht zur
islamfeindlichkeit zustimmung in
deutschland und da konnte man sehen dass
eigentlich die große mehrheit der
muslime in deutschland durchaus die
demokratischen westlichen werte
unterstützt
trotzdem empfinden eigentlich sehr sehr
viele deutsche den islam als starke
bedrohung
also dieses ganze klima scheint sich ja
schon zu verhärten
schätzen sie die situation ein ich habe
auch das jetzt so ist ein politisches
unternehmertum verstärkt noch gibt das
versucht kapital zu schlagen aus den
ereignissen also diese bewegung in
deutschland auch marine le pen in
frankreich hatte auch schon bekommen
jetzt mit vorstößen quasi das wasser auf
ihre mühlen zu bringen das und
vielleicht auch noch dann ungeschickt
dass sie nicht eingeladen wird zu diesem
marsch der republik verstehe ich nicht
gerade seine partei geht auch an den
wahlen teilnimmt und zum demokratischen
spiel gehört dass mitgliedern ausgrenzt
das ist auch kontraproduktiv finde ich
also diese gefahr besteht dass ich hier
etwas verschärft verhärtet aber meine
unmittelbare fahren jetzt in letzten
drei tagen ist auch ihr positiv ich fand
es ist gut wie unmittelbar auch die
europäischen imams teilgenommen haben
und eingebunden wurden von den medien in
die in die diskussion und in die in die
kundgebung der empörung der trauer dass
das ist sehr gut geglückt meines
erachtens auch sofort gesehen ja es gibt
auch wieder muslime unter den opfern
nicht wahr man weiß auch dass die
meisten opfer dieses islamistischen
terrors muslime sind also all das ist
relativ breit diskutiert worden ist und
ich glaube es gibt ein gesamt
bewusstsein darüber dass es hier nicht
um den westen gegen den islam geht
sondern dass das ein vielschichtiges
problem ist dass man auch nur mit
differenzierter regierungskunst lösen
kann da da bin ich eher er jetzt
optimistisch weniger optimistisch bin
ich bei der selbst so ich glaube es gibt
es viele kundgebungen ja natürlich nicht
schluss für charlie
aber ich bin in dem sinne nicht charlie
dass ich jetzt hingehen und solche
karikaturen zeichnen ich war also ich
glaube jetzt sehr viele werden sich
zurückhaltend gerade weil man eben kein
öl ins feuer gießen will also die
gewalttat doch indem sie ihnen das team
vielleicht erreicht dass das die
selbstzensur zu nehmen das gab es ja
auch schon vor diesem attentat
aber ich glaube sie wird zu nehmen und
eben das ist dann schade dass das ich
doch eine gesellschaft eben letztlich
reduzieren lässt
in ihrer meinungsäußerung sei durch
gebaut das ist eine traurige einzigen
vielleicht bin ich vielleicht gibt es
millionenfach neue charlies die sich
manifestieren
aber ich habe da meine meine bedenken
wahrlich ich sage nicht dass unser bus
als auch nicht wir würden nie
mohammed-karikaturen drucken oder oder
oder zeichen denke das ist dass ist eine
diskussion die man je nach konflikt
gesellschaftliche konfliktsituation
ansehen muss nicht die denke im moment
wo man aufgewühlten konfliktsituationen
wo sich eben tatsächlich zwei lager
abzeichen eine eine starken des rechten
politischen lager das stimmung macht
nicht und auf der einen seite eine
betroffene islamische migranten
migranten sektor da finde ich es muss
man sich überlegen was was ob mann ob
man es vorher gießen will oder nicht
aber nicht grundsätzlich sagen aufgrund
dieser dieses diese attacke da sind wir
jetzt zurückhalten damit auch die
zeichnung im gegenteil wir haben das hat
dazu geführt dass wir eine eine eine
palette von von charlie hebdo
karikaturen jetzt gezeigt haben viele
andere medien mit uns nicht wir haben
sie auch nicht verpixelt nicht das denke
ich das wäre das aus der zum teil
gemacht als wurde zum teil gemacht das
war sicher dass sie hier falsch ich
glaube ich dass man sich sorgen machen
muss dass dieser täter sich mundtot
machen lässt ist ein wichtiger punkt für
mich ist stative es gibt es gibt
verschiedene spielarten von motive es
gibt die die freche die die ihre
provokative und es geht euch die
zwischen den zeilen und da das erinnere
mich an die an die zeit des nebelspalter
selbst die der nebelspalter groß gemacht
hat und das ist er
die zeit des dritten reiches und des
zweiten weltkrieges und da gibt es
wirklich im insel in den jahren der
größten bedrohung für die schweiz auch
drei vier jahre in der netzsparte keine
einzige hitler karikatur also kein
hitler porträt abgebildet hat weil das
auch wirklich sensorik worden wäre
dennoch sind ganz viele karikaturen
erschienen die das publikum
entschlüsseln konnte die und unter
diesem rat dadurch gesegelt sind 100
sensor nicht betroffen gewesen sind und
die letztlich auch dazu geführt hat dass
der nebelspalter in dieser zeit bekannt
geworden ist gesetzt wurden ist einfach
weil das zwischen den zeilen ich genauso
gut funktionieren kann das ist die
stärkere sortiert es passt sich im
zusammenspiel mit den rezipienten den
gegebenheiten auch an wenn es sein muss
und deshalb muss ich mir keine sorgen
machen dass man nicht auch einen weg
finden kann ohne mohammed karikaturen
ganz gute kontakte hat sich wollte
gemacht auf jahren genau einen schluss
werbespot weil wir sind am ende unserer
zeit wirklich passiert auch diese diese
mit die vereine sortieren ich die er mit
dem florett hat ihre mit dem mit dem
fein geführten zeichenstift und meine
uns in unser zeichen fertig ist auch ein
vorbild in dieser richtung nie habe ich
bei ihm jeden
die geringste befürchten dass seine
satire erhitzen oder r unten zielt nicht
um sein bild war lebte nicht mehr das
scheint sich jetzt über einheiten auf
grund der solidarität aber sicher nicht
tot ist die meinungsäusserungsfreiheit
das nenne ich im schlusswort ich bedanke
mich ganz herzlich res strehle frauen
schöne war marco ratschiller dass sie zu
diesem gespräch gekommen sind dankeschön
die meinungsfreiheit über die wir jetzt
gesprochen haben ist auch ein herzstück
des projekts europa ist die
verantwortungsträger der europäischen
union verstehen europa aus freiheits und
friedensprojekt aber auch als
bürokratischer moloch und als knacknuss
für die schweiz
darüber spricht in seiner ersten sendung
als frischgebackener sternstunde
moderator stephan klapproth am nächsten
sonntag und zwar mit dem eben
abgetretenen eu kommissionspräsidenten
josé manuel barroso in dem die einen den
zahn aus brüssel die anderen den pudel
von angela merkel sein schauten sie zu
[Musik]